hello and welcome to this video playing
dungeon 04 and okay what do we have here
some bishops game or well he white has a
choice here d 393 and so on couple of
moves okay I had that had that earlier
in a game and I could have no idea why
white is playing this kind of stuff it's
just immediately equal I mean it's not
very interesting admittedly but it's
yeah it's it's basically immediately
conceding equality
okay okay I could take you five it was a
bit was lazy this move was f6 possible
hmm maybe he could have trickin if I
made on the aid I was getting ambitious
already of course 97 hmm anyway okay
let's see
writes provides probably equaled stop
with night c4 is not yours yet
thought you might be just giving me the
bishop pair like that but it can always
let's say yeah cut it in half by snide
c4 yeah I wonder maybe I can take it
this is the easiest way to play Knight
85 was looking a little bit annoying
no it looks very eco I'm happy that I
have the King star in the middle that
might be helpful but it shouldn't be any
anything significant
oh yeah so probably this 48 it's very
simplifying but it's hard to not impose
on the default okay so is there some way
to do it you know to do something
naughty 64 okay and this will actually
with material it's 93 that's Chad check
and mighty form
okay hmm I wonder bees b6 actually I can
just go be 6 C 3 as a self trap of that
night that no now I now be 5s is winning
the night mr. damn jen is no way out
it's a fence of funny United white
resins yeah it was very equal ish okay
well I'm not quite sure what why does
serve going for he and this opening it
looks very equal and Jan yeah what I
wonder actually if he could have played
night xt5 yeah he could have played that
97 was I was a very stupid move I should
probably play age 6 h-6 or something and
it definitely has something else then
this because you can win the pawn due to
rook the eight made in 697 why does a
pawn up that was yeah that was a soft
spot that game yeah this was very simple
solution but Knight a5 looked looked
annoying and I don't think rook moves
help maybe night a4 is the better choice
looking over looking at c5 this was a
bit uncomfortable because now yeah he
doesn't want me to take and if he takes
himself he's now in slide trouble
because I'm on the default and my night
is good here he has to be really really
careful and I think pretty pretty
quickly it turned to turn to be a night
it was not helping anymore this is the
problem after that i'm winning with 95
he has to play 91 it seems and that's
not exactly great something like that
okay five every night here black is
better it's not clear if i can win but
I'm better him ya know this is
essentially when even though we did not
need to lose that quickly
can take see towards well but this is
stronger says lower traps III is just
winning the night and other moves I just
takes you to next without giving him any
counter play here the night is strapped
is really funny that has no squares yeah
there was a somewhat lucky game though
he could have taken only five early on i
blundered 35 porn but after that I was
it was a pretty decent game I think okay
thanks for watching